hello and welcome to this week's edition
of The Gadget Lab show I'm Christina
Bonnington and I am Roberto Baldwin
today we've got a cool new update to the
light rail camera and some updates on my
wallet lyst adventures first up what's
up with Metro so like sure they didn't
release a new camera the same camera
same light-filled technology long lens
but what they have done is they've
updated the software and so now you have
manual settings so you have an ISO
sensitivity you could adjust and you
have the shutter speed so you know is oh
it's it's it's a throwback to film you
know you speech film speeds like 400 200
and shutter speed obviously is how long
the shutter will stay open now the cool
thing about this is that you could have
the shutter stay open for up to eight
seconds which if you're a fan of light
painting with light like lasers leaving
the shutter open or you know light
trails from cars you can do it now at
the light row which is actually pretty
cool and then of course you know
everything it's in the foreground the
background you can adjust the focus yeah
yeah because electro takes what it takes
planes of images instead of just a 2d
image so you can tap it captures like a
whole like cube of light almost so you
can tap in the foreground or the
background of like a finished image and
change the whole photograph yeah you can
you can adjust the the depth of field
where how you want to look you want
something the foreground you can tap on
it that's in focus background that's in
focus so it's a it's pretty cool like I
said it's not a new camera so if you
already have the old camera you're
you're set it just it's just an update
updated go crazy knock yourself out if
you are interested in lytro camera it's
five hundred dollars for 16 gigabyte and
it's four hundred dollars for 8
gigabytes it's pretty pricey it isn't
wait I it depends if you're like us huge
photography nut then yet I think it's a
cool little thing to have if you just
want to point and shoot camera this is
probably a
it's more than you need and be it's not
really made for printing it's more for
sharing online so and it doesn't work
with Instagram I know you're all crazy
about the Instagram now so eight times
optical zoom not digital zoom so that's
pretty nice so like your camera cool
awesome and then this week I so if you
are familiar for the past three weeks I
have been going Wallace I've just been
using my smartphone as my wallet so I'm
using a lot of different apps to do
payment so i can actually eat places and
order groceries and buy whatever clothes
or something and this past week I took
that experiment on the road to a
vacation to Hawaii so that seems like
the worst job ever having to go to
Hawaii for work yeah I mean I went to
Hawaii and do my job enough so it ended
up that like I could go to Hawaii on a
budget so I was like why not and you
know I looked up beforehand before I
made any reservations i looked up you
know are there places that i can
actually eat I want to get there and
starve can I actually order tickets
online and kind of do that order tickets
online or through an app and everything
seemed to fall into place and so I went
for it and then yeah but once I was
there use Google Wallet a lot to get
groceries and then went on a lot of
hikes and walks on the beaches so now
getting to Hawaii that now that's a big
the big issue is that you have to go
through TSA and then you know for all
during the TSA they want to see your
ticket and they want see your idea is to
carry dinner in that little ultraviolet
light to make sure you haven't made it
at Kinkos or something so what happened
there right so I went through um I don't
quite recommend this but I went through
the TSA line without my ID I mean
technically I did actually have my ID in
my backpack I do I carry my ID in a
credit card on me just in case if I run
into an emergency but basically I'm
living as if I don't have that on me um
so I get up to the TSA agent I tell them
that I I don't have it I said that I
forgot it at home which I have often
done before
and I was so nervous I'm getting nervous
just talking about it and remembering
whatever it is the man yeah it's not
just like it's not the guy at the
starbucks is a gross square doesn't work
we're gonna do this is the man throw you
in jail yeah that's right the first TSA
agent you know the one that's sitting
there and checking everything um you
know very like Stern just like you know
you forgot your ID do you have you no
prescription medication or credit cards
anything that can we can use to verify
your identity I'm like no so I had to
stand off to the side while everyone
else went through and I was like oh god
these people probably think I'm a
terrorist or something and then you know
the vent to so she called two
supervisors over and they were really
they're really kind and understanding
I'd have felt like a consent form they
basically did a background check they
were asking me questions and relaying
the answers to the person on the phone
and we're like talking to you talk to
your mom really Christina and well and I
don't understand the fact that
prescription medicine is a form of ID
yeah like you just have like a little
hears of my container Christie
prescription it well how do I know it's
you and they just pop it open and take
one like well you wouldn't you wouldn't
take that medicine unless that was you
right I don't know how that works
alright but yeah so then they passed I
answered my question correctly and I got
to go on through and get all nudie scans
fun get on my flight yeah yeah there you
go coming back it was kind of
nerve-wracking to that TSA agent
originally told me no I could not get
through and I had the website pulled up
on my phone I was like actually I looked
it up and I can and she just stared at
me for like 30 seconds and then call
their supervisors over so so the moral
of stories you can get onto a plane
without an ID all you need is
prescription medication or you want you
you're totally cool just waiting around
in them calling somebody who knows too
much information about you yeah
definitely but last resort I mean I
would definitely next time I fly I'll
my ID on me for sure at least for now
maybe 10 years from now we'll have some
sort of digital form of a ID good I hope
so bar codes yeah tattooed on our faces
like fringe well that's it for this
week's edition of The Gadget Lab show
tune in next week for more who knows
gadgets gadgets in a lab by